and it's on the rails just like a
mousetrap game yes beautiful
well played it's a crowd-pleaser I'm
Tania Morimoto and these are my two
robots for toodle-oo seven it's
essentially a giant ratchet I have this
lead screw that will allow me to extend
almost to the top of the pyramid when
the robot drives off this mother here
moves the entire arm this way very light
delicate arm they will drive up the ramp
and on the end of the string is an
electromagnet it's the same idea for a
rocket launching off the launch pad it's
compact and it's it's quite put a bust
and this string you know pulls pulls
tolls gradually this thing comes out
extends all the way and then pulls pulls
pulls pulls pull some more and actually
in the end I decided that I cared less
about scoring and more about having my
robot show off because I think it can do
a lot of really awesome things so I
actually haven't danced on the field
rather than score
you can't just get stuck on one idea and
you have to be able to adapt you should
always make time to test your design
building redesigning improving and
troubleshooting never take shortcuts
when you're machining something will end
up coming back to bite you in the end
one of the new things I learned was
about permanent magnet motors looking at
the the current torque curve and
figuring out how to get to that max
power point it's one thing to have an
idea on paper and a totally different
thing to turn that into a working robot
I was sort of debating between doing
mechanical engineering or software
engineering and it's been really fun
just to sort it you know get my hands
dirty and really do some tangible design
and end up with a nice finished product
you